try that again with the mic on
the one o'clock i'm going to call the
subcommittee work session for senate
bill 282
to order and just a little bit of
background which everybody may know but
um
so we had um house bill 1192 on this
subject
that passed the house it went to the
senate it passed the senate and
their committee and then the full senate
passed it on consent yesterday
so
this bill is after going through you
know the enroll bill process will be
going to the governor and i don't see
any reason why
he wouldn't sign it um
and then we got senate bill 282 which is
his work session with four and
the intent had been for it to be
identical to 1192 there's one sentence
that's different um
i came here with an amendment we can
discuss other options with an amendment
but all that amendment did would be to
make the two identical
but after talking to the chair uh
carol mcguire she said
if you know rather than do that if if
we're fine with what was in 1192 the
best thing would just be to itl
senate bill 282 because we don't need
two bills on the same topic
um
so anybody else in the subcommittee want
to say anything
i i agree with that assessment although
if there are changes that we want to
make to the statute
we could do so we could just build a
vehicle to do that but we would have to
write a contingency such that uh
whatever we pass out of
our committee
only takes effect after right actually
yeah that's the carol said that she said
if we want to make further changes her
suggestion would be to
um have an amendment to replace all of
and had a later effective date than
1192. so yeah
so there wouldn't be a question of which
one took precedence so thanks
you can make the effective date whenever
you want and then put four one uh
minute after
two
sure later
and that's how all that takes care of us
okay all right and i would recommend
that
you start with 11 magnitude since that's
the thing that's past those bodies i
agree
and rather than trying to
miss me 282
and i think we should look at that
and if we need to amend that and we
return this
use that
as senator 2h would pass it
all right i agree
so yeah so we should work off of uh 282
or 1192 sorry
um so
actually if you can turn the mic on and
have your uh the mic quite close to your
mouth
so i'm molly gendro and i represent the
association the new hampshire
acupuncture and asian medicine
association
and i'm diane chase i'm a vice chair on
the new hampshire acupuncture licensing
board
i represent
myself
as an acupuncturist who's been impacted
by our law dramatically and in
negatively and that's why i approach to
try and make the changes that i want
i'm elizabeth rob i'm a community
acupuncturist there are no community
acupuncturists who sit on the licensing
board so there's no one who represents
my co-workers and myself we have a
distinctive approach of doing things
i'm with the
people's organization of community
acupuncture
we again we have a different approach
than say private room acupuncturists and
so um
there are aspects of this law that make
it hard for people to get licensed in
new hampshire we want to make that
easier like reciprocity easier
could you briefly give us some idea of
the difference between what a community
acupuncture it is versus other types yes
i'm happy too so
in community acupuncture clinics instead
of putting patients in a single room
by themselves and treating them on a
treatment table we have an open
community space we're often treating
patients in reclining chairs it's like a
big living room and we pray
we mostly use distal points to treat
patients so if you were to come in say
and get a treatment for your back i
wouldn't put the needles directly in
your back i would just have you sit in a
reclining chair roll up your pant legs
to your knees your sleeves to your
elbows and i would use points in your
arms and hands legs and feet head and
ears to treat your back pain you know
using the meridians that run through
your back and what we do is um we've we
do this at a reduced cost so how much is
private room acupuncture
can you want to give a range
how much
so so a private room clinic might be 55
to 155 dollars 25 125. so the clinic
where i work we charge a sliding scale
of 20 to 40 dollars patients choose what
they want to pay
um there's a you know we're just a
different group we just have a different
approach
and we tend to be bigger clinics with
more practitioners keeping open flexible
hours
so what i'm getting is i mean except
you're not
no i'm using needles
i don't know some of those terms that
you're using is it a matter
i thought you said you weren't in those
types
oh not in the back
okay i don't necessarily know what
meridian's a leg are and you got to
assume that we know nothing other than i
know what a needle is okay
so in the community if i could speak in
the community acupuncture room people
are in recliner chairs in their clothes
like when i was trained i was trained to
put somebody into a hospital gown and
then have them lay on the table
right and that's
frequently how private room acupuncture
happens
but in community you're not taking your
clothes off in the group
all right thank you
one thing i'd
what we can do here is he says as we
said start with 1192.
i don't know if anybody in the committee
feels there need to be changes and but
we we could deal with that first and
then what i'd like to do
is um you know we can talk about any
other pro this pros and amendment or
other changes uh with respect to 1192.
and could you introduce yourself the
person who came in
yes sir my name is vicky irwin i'm a
licensed acupuncturist in new hampshire
a member of the state association as
well as the acupuncture licensing board
okay
yeah we for the record vicky irwin irwin
you have to speak with a microphone like
this
you have to sort of eat it
almost
my name is vicky irwin i'm a
licensed acupuncturist here in new
hampshire as well as a member of the
state association and the acupuncture
licensing board
okay thank you
but you're representing yourself
yes okay
anybody on the subcommittee
want to say anything before we open it
up to
representative marshall i would like to
ask the questions
i mean we're kind of close together but
any questions that i can understand this
uh board of acupuncture licensing draft
legislation that comes from your group
have you guys seen it
will you share it with
um
okay any anything else for anyone on the
subcommittee
yep
thank you mr chair so i just want to i
looked through
the
1192 and
the changes that
were made by the senate
to me
made 1192 a hybrid between 1192 and 282.
would anybody else concur that that's
what
happened
the senate didn't change 1192 after it
left our committee
so the
okay so these are the changes that it
left our committee with that's correct
okay thank you right uh representative
marsh uh
brought forward an amendment that was
intended to make
uh 1192 the same as 282
there was one sentence that somehow
ended up being different right we were
asked by the board to make an additional
change which we incorporated in our
amendment uh at the time so that's where
we left it okay what change was that do
you know i can't i can't keep track i'm
just trying to figure out which change
yes uh it it's in in fact if you look at
the amendment that representative league
has brought forward mm-hmm
this was the additional change that we
made
to 1192
after uh while it was in our commitment
right i mean there's one of them is a
word order change that isn't i don't
think significant but the key is
it adds um at the end there
let's hold about license to practice
acupuncture from another uh no no that's
not the one that's it's got another
it's got nc aom including if successors
or predecessors it's the main change is
uh adding that including its successors
or predecessors which was in other
places
in 282 and 1192 but it wasn't um one was
not covered
and so that's what this was intended to
fix
mr chair can i make a suggestion
certainly uh can i suggest we look at
the board's draft here
start at the beginning and see which
sections are already and what has passed
what things might be new and what
whether we think that this is a
reasonable change or whether we think
it's something that really ought to have
a public hearing and be a bill next year
okay um if
as far as a way of doing if you'd like
to go through it
and then
i i would like to do it that way because
i think that that will accomplish what
we're doing
i think that's a good idea
so looking at this draft legislation the
first part seems to change the word
oriental to the word asian in a number
of places
does anyone have any objection to that
i'm taking a look at
[Music]
1192 and i'd look through here and i'm
not seeing oh so this is changing other
parts of the rsa that's right then
what's touch they're asking us to change
some other parts
which would be germaine certainly okay
and if they want to change oriental to
asian i don't have any objection to
doing that
i
since it costs the state of new
hampshire about ten thousand dollars to
bring a bill forward if we can do that
now we end up saving the state money
particularly if it's a relatively minor
thing like that so all right i would
certainly be be in favor of doing that
sort of a change if that's what people
want to do i agree and looking through
the uh part one that's all that's in
there and in part two
uh section two in uh
four that's what's there
and then in uh six
actually is this one changed in our bill
g2 well section one is no section two is
new which also
is
oriental to asian and adds
the change to ac a
hm and
ncc aom and including its predecessors
and successors again
i don't see those as being anything that
anyone objects to
no and uh
so we're going through here if anybody
has a problem with any of these you know
let us know
right if we go to section three
um
the significant change there i believe
is already in what was passed which
says no more than two section terms that
is in section three
of the bill that's already passed
is there any difference here between
what we've already passed
i'm gonna ask about section three
roman numeral one
number one where we strike out
b n c c a o
our bill or their no i'm looking at
their bill okay yes
hold a current valid license to practice
acupuncture
that's in 1192 on page 1 lines 14
through 17.
okay so i believe this whole section
three is
something that's already been done
yep
agree
um
moving on to section four um
i believe that this section again is
something that we've already addressed
i'm looking for exactly where i think
it's at the beginning uh section one of
the bill
deals with 329.99
yes that's great yeah yeah
actually all that the bill does is for
that section is it changes
what does this actually change
okay yeah we've got the chain
[Music]
e12
what is it
okay so the the the section of section
four of the amendment that we received
is similar to
page
right it's got the uh on a reached age
of majority that's fine and b
it has the nca om certification or
equivalent
he talks about the
licensing fee it talks about
professional character and it up to line
10 whose requirements are simply equal
to or exceed the requirements of
so section 4 is in the bill that passed
the senate and section 4.
exactly exactly you know even going down
the apprenticeship is looking to be
basically
correct okay but the
b has a major problem it actually took
out the very point of what i initiated
which one
line b
what was originally struck was the
current active
no it's right here has current active n
c a o m yeah
we want to strike current active
because that requires that we pay dues
to our trade organization
in addition to our license well it says
or equivalent certification
approved by the board it's just the
current active great people should be
ncms ncc or certified
but if you don't pay the dues they will
not turn out your test results so you
can't get licenses in other states after
a certain amount of time
and i am required to pay a state
licensing fee and more for that ncac am
active stats i hear what you're saying
would not the board be able to approve
prior ncc aom certification that may not
be current and active as equivalent
certification if the board so desire
can you can you please repeat that oh
we've already inserted into statute here
or equivalent certification approved by
the board
what is being contended here is that we
should strike the words current active
so that one only has to be ncc aom
certified
now
would as an alternative would not
require any change in statute
would not the board be able to accept an
ncc aom certification
that is not current
because they didn't pay their dues
as being equivalent
if they so desire
ncc aom also requires a certain amount
of continuing education which is then
mirrored in quite a lot of the rest of
this bill so i do believe maintaining it
is important
understood so you could uh
have some other maintenance of
certification process that you approve
that if they did that and had a prior
ncc aom certification
that could at least hypothetically be
acceptable to the board
right or it might not even require prior
ncc home certification they could have
whatever the board could decide whatever
they want basically
okay so two things the the paragraph
about ceus the chair of the licensing
board has contested what's in here
because it implies that you can only get
it through nccumceus
okay so what's in here right now i
believe is one of the things that she
would like to change
that's number one number two
current active status if you've been
certified you have passed the test so
why you have to maintain and pay dues
when you've already passed the test to
prove your credibility and your
competence
why i should pay more than my licensing
fee every year for that i don't know and
i will further explain that the last
course i took for those ceus was in
astrology from the ncc aom website
so from here on out i'm taking astrology
classes because they offer a lot of them
so the new hampshire citizens can be
protected from me because i have learned
astrology okay actually actually
and we've had the same argument with
medical licenses and i had a bill to
that effect a couple of sessions ago so
i hear what you're saying
um
but i i i was not did not prevail in
getting the the bottom line was the
public determined that some sort of
continuing education was considered in
the public interest and i respect that
yeah i agree i'm we we require in new
hampshire by law 30 ceus every two years
so
that's fine but paying the current
active status fee that is the problem i
actually have a question so uh does the
board
um have anything specified for
continuing education other than
that required to maintain uh current act
of ncc om certification
so is there another option
has been the position all along in the
law and the board i'm asking right now
has the board approved any other
there are other ways to obtain your ceus
there are a number of other courses that
can be approved by the board and
accepted as appropriate continuing
education however
i would also caution that astrology
courses won't keep your ncc aom current
because there are ethics courses and
safety courses part of the requisites as
well
okay but there
are there any um alternatives to ncclm
that the board has currently approved or
are there people who are licensed based
on that or is this just
if someone asked you could do it
to my knowledge we've not been asked to
do that ncc aom has been a pretty
standard right right now it's across the
board requirement
mr chair yes yeah i i believe that
we need to phrase this slightly
differently because existing law that
we're trying to amend here currently
says that they have to have a current
act of ncc aom certification
but we're adding into the law or the
equivalent certification right i get
that
they're going to have to rewrite their
rules and the question is are they going
to rewrite their rules to allow
alternative forms of continuing
education which i believe is the intent
right i see another thing here in 1192
on page 2 near the bottom on lines 35
and 36
under it's under continuing education
it says uh maintaining current active
nccm certification shall fulfill the
continuing education requirement
and it doesn't offer any alternative
down here
yes
so this is um thank you this is this is
reminding me of the discussion that we
had
four years ago because one of the disc
one of the points
that
several
acupuncturists were making at the time
was that the nca om ncc aom was the only
um recognized test and licensing
and there and that's when we started
this ore equivalent
and that was accepted by both bodies and
then that was the house bill 1314. that
was one of the big points of 1314
and that bill passed the house and went
to the senate and got lost during covet
so
when i saw this
i thought that that was
one of the important things so we if
we're saying that we're going to have
nca om certification or equivalent we
have to make sure that that
policy carries out throughout the bill
right and it looks like it doesn't cover
section five
and you got a comment
um
okay okay um a couple different things
so it's been in our statute all along
that we need current active status with
the ncc aom but it's also in our statute
that we need 30 ceus
every two years to renew our new
hampshire licenses
and
so that's 60 ceus every four years which
is exactly what we need for ncc aom so
i've had people turn in letters saying
that it's completely redundant and
burdensome on a small business owner to
have to keep this nccaom certification
in addition to
keeping
a new hampshire license
it's they're already competing
completing the same amount of ceus for
new hampshire and submitting the proof
and the certificates and then
submitting the same proof and
certificates to the ncc aom this
national agency when we've already
passed their
right tests
actually it looks like i mean
even if we think the rest of the bill's
fine there's an inconsistency because to
get certification it appears you there
are options other there could be options
other ncclm but the way the bill's
written ncclm certification is the only
way
to get renewed so that's a that is
definitely a problem and i believe in
the rules california ceus are accepted
in new hampshire
that's correct so it's not just ncca oh
i'm approved ceus also if we're adding
or equivalent certification if we're
accepting someone to new hampshire who's
taken the california acupuncture
licensing exam as their equivalent are
they then expected to maintain an active
license in california as their
equivalent approved certification that
mirrors ncc aom that wouldn't make sense
it's just you've taken
a test either ncc aom or equivalent and
right now that's the cali and then you
maintain your ces for the state of new
hampshire and then if you want to pay
ncc aom if you feel there's benefit to
ncc aom then that should be a choice not
a mandate by law
can i make a suggestion
because i i hear both sides here and i
think that you're making valid points
why don't we add
at the end of section five
where right now we we've struck some
language from the statute including the
30 continuing education hours that was
just mentioned and the sentence is
maintaining current active nc caom
certification shall fulfill the
continuing current education requirement
why don't we add a sentence right there
the board shall adopt rules regarding
alternative means of fulfilling the
continuing educational requirement
particularly since they already have
that in the rules
that is in the board's amendment
that is the language as i said the chair
is for this
she testifies
in the amendment
um x on page four
of their the board's amendment as a
conditional renewal of license the board
shall require east licensing to show
proof of having completed for each
biennial period
continuing education at approved
institutions or as approved by the board
okay and the board the board does
approve other ceus every year there's an
annual meeting elizabeth and i both
served as board members on the
association in the past
um and i attended and got ceus at annual
meetings sponsored by the association
approved by the board so yes that does
happen so if we were to take this
language
in the middle of page towards the bottom
of page four number ten and use that to
replace the language in the bill for
section five yeah that's what we have
everybody
yes everyone
yep okay all right let's do that that's
a good point
um you're sort of uh
driving the detail here would you be
willing to uh request the amendment uh
i'd be glad to do the amendment here you
would like me to do so yes as long as we
reach consensus at the end of the day
obviously
yeah i mean probably the thing to do is
to have a uh
at the end
maybe have a marked up copy of alumni
1192 or something and then we can just
review it and then the subcommittee can
vote on whether we recommend that is
what i would suggest
right my only issue is that my laptop
wouldn't boot this morning so i uh
probably will
okay we'll do it
i just don't want to end this with a
misunderstanding and further all right
so we got we got through the section
five here um
actually we were using the board
language to go through
um section 5 of the board's language is
that already included
let's look back at it 328 g9
the next section of their proposed
amendment is the certified acupuncture
detoxification specialist my
recollection was this was already in the
bill and elaine is shaking her head yes
we're looking on their amendment where
their
328 g9a to read as follows
um so which page on there is it's that's
at the bottom of page four okay and
elaine is saying this is already in in
what was passed by the house and the
senate
uh and i'm just looking for where to
make sure that it is in fact there
yeah i didn't print out the current
statute which i probably should have
done but they don't they're not changing
anything
except on the next page but that general
supervision
is also on the back of 1192.
another part of this is
yes
yep okay so we don't need
their section five at all
okay does anybody think we need this
section
no
not we'll say not needed
okay uh scope of practice
uh oriental to asian yes so i think
that's fine yep
now i have a real problem with changing
the dentistry statue as part of this
because that makes it a non-german
amendment and that creates
lots of issues
so we're just going to say no for
section seven and uh
eight because we're not going to do that
um
and at the end we have to have a
contingency
okay well let me see we
yes so we want to have this new
amendment take place one minute after
the adoption of 11.92
what i would like to do
is because we have a couple new sections
where section 1 is new
section 2 is new
and we are changing
the paragraph
on page four in the middle
which is replacing what's already in the
bill
and number six is new so if we write if
we create a whole replaceable bill
to take effect one minute after what
just passed the senate yeah with just
those changes
that will work
and there's a question
um it's a comment
the way that this is written the current
act of nc
certification i do not believe the board
has the authority to ignore that
the way that
it is being interpreted
yes if you leave current active nccm
certification in there
well we could say
this is it's this part right here
can we just say has
nca
certification or equivalent
has has ncc aom or equivalence
certification
yeah just take that that would work
no
down here well the way it's read it says
has current nccem equivalent uh
certification or equivalence
certification approved by the board
so that gives them the she doesn't like
the word it's current active because
you it's the word current active because
you
right it implies
that you have to have
current active ncaom certification
the or if you're using the right-hand
side of the ore then the left-hand side
is completely irrelevant i'm not opposed
to remove well
here's the problem
and why i'm not sure it's good to remove
that
what this is saying is that you have two
options here one is you have some
equivalent certification approved by the
board
um and that's fine
or
you have nccaom certification but
you know
if you had gotten the certification a
long time ago and it isn't currently
active that means you haven't had
ongoing
training for that and you haven't kept
up and you're doing that instead of some
equivalent approved by the board so i
don't know that every state requires
ceus
right period whether you're nccm
certified or not
and not all states require nccum
a number do not
and
maybe the majority do not require active
current status so mr chair and i'm
looking i'm going back because this is
like bringing me back
so in house bill 1314 we struck out
current active okay so we had has ncc
aom certification or equivalent
certification approved by the board or
has successfully passed the california
acupuncture licensing examination
through examination or credential
document review so
we had taken the words current active
out i'm fine with that and i don't i
presumably don't need the ore california
thing because the board could
accept that if they wanted correct all
right
is that any issue with that
i'm not quite sure i understand all of
it but
california is now
requiring ncc aom they they moved
towards that
the earlier argument i think they're
required to replicate
um duplicating your submissions for your
ceus if you have your ncca om active and
current the license
this actually made it a little bit
easier for a number of uh constituents
because you didn't have to strictly
adhere to 15 this two-year period or 30
this two-year period 30 this two-year
period as long as you had your 60 in
your four years and maintained your
current certification we as the board
can simply
go online and see that you are current
and active
and know that you're up to date
reasonably up to date on your
certification and your ceus you might
have only 13 in this two year period and
then 17 in the next and but as long as
it added up at the end of the four years
that was adequate i know in some states
like new massachusetts i was looking at
their laws this morning
it the dates must follow exactly you
take extra ceus before they're required
well that was good for you but it
doesn't help
here we it was actually allowing a lot
more flexibility as well as an ease on
the board of checking the ceu status of
somebody rather than requiring us to
look through every single applicant's
every single ceu submitted what but if
we took the requirement for current
active
um you know the board presumably could
still for people who do have current
active certification look at that for
the education requirement yes and we're
not looking for that to be the only way
we were simply looking to add that as an
easiest way okay but taking the words
out of there i don't think will affect i
have a suggestion that i hope would make
everybody happy why don't we create
three ways
we can have current active ncc aom
certification which is probably what
you're gonna do most of the time
we have or equivalent certification
approved by the board which means you
can develop something else
and we can put in the middle or prior
ncc aom certification with documentation
of continuing education pursuant to rsa
328 g colon 9x which is the part we just
talked about
would that work for everybody i think
it's fine but it's also redundant yes
it's redundant it's boots it's it's
suspenders and bill that works sometimes
if it gets everybody to yes and we can
stop arguing about it i'm happy to do
this i just want to say that we actually
have a very good ceu policy
in new hampshire that if you take more
than the amount you can apply them next
year i don't know any other state that
does that and that definitely helps
people
so i just want to inject some
you know so i just want to make sure i
understand the board is now going to be
responsible for setting up the
guidelines for an entire system of
standards that meet ncc aom
for the state of new hampshire
specifically no we're we're giving you
the option that if somebody comes in
with a prior certificate that is not
currently active and evidence that
they've kept up with their continuing
education
which you already have a policy on and
it's elsewhere in the in the law that
then you can accept that for less
okay that was the third option but the
second one in between with the or the
fourth one is for equivalent
certification which means that if you
guys want to you can come up with some
other pathway in the rules that you
consider to be equivalent and we are
good with that
sounds good
my last question is tony would you
prefer that i do this amendment as a
replace all and contain all the language
of the original bill or do it as just a
contingency that can take effect right
after the other bill to just make the
changes
i would suggest it just be easier to see
the changes if it only
included it was it basically became an
amendment that that uh just added the
change
282 with the changes we're discussing
today and took effect later that would
be my preference and i'm happy to do it
that way i'll just go down to ols and do
it great thank you
this is just i don't know if this is
concerning but what if someone was
licensed here in new hampshire
they went through the nccom
certification then they took maybe 20
years away from practicing and now they
want to be renewed again is that then
they'd have to show
like 30 ceus and that they were once
you know certified by
ncpom my understanding is that your
policy currently is 30 ceus per year
with some flexibility so you can shift
things from one year to another so if
somebody took a 10-year break that means
that they would have to come up with 300
ceus which i suppose they could do if
they really worked at it okay
i think that makes sense
just just
okay and um
what i'd suggest is um
if everybody who has an interest in this
could uh leave an email address then
maybe we can uh
i don't know
let them see a copy of the amendment and
i would be glad to circulate it to a
list if people give me a list of email
addresses right and
uh
just a last check to make sure that way
if there's a sudden panic you guys can
send me an email and i can correct it
yeah
jack if you could uh have your notebook
with their sign up and let up
let them add emails somehow
the point that i made during testimony
which you weren't here the other day is
most people probably keep their nccm
active but some people want the choice
they don't feel
like the ncca
represents them
also the ncc iom is
a trade association or they're a
certifying body either way they're a
test agency that acts as a trade
association technically
and
many of us feel very uncomfortable about
the salaries that they make considering
what acupuncturists make when we don't
and we don't feel like they represent us
so some people i'm probably going to
continue with my active certification
with them but i know several people in
new hampshire who don't want to
i i can tell you that physicians feel
exactly the same way okay they're
licensing boards so okay you're not
alone in that field
and this isn't new i heard similar
things from my father who was a doctor
okay is there
other than getting email addresses
is there
any other points anyone wants to raise
either on the
subcommittee or
not
i believe
that
if we
make an amendment
before the meeting
we're going to have to meet again to
pass the amendment as a subcommittee
but we can do that
in one second right
so let's yeah right so i guess we're
meeting uh the whole committee is
meeting let me we've got a number of
meetings coming up monday and tuesday of
next week right now in the amendment now
we'll have it on monday
right we could we could do it monday or
or just to leave some time in case we
could we're meeting on
tuesday so
i could i could ask them to schedule
also needs to be some notice for the
subcommittee work session so
i could put in a request to schedule one
for 9 30 in the morning on tuesday that
would be fine
okay
so i recommend the people who are
attending the subcommittee meeting look
at the
look at the amendment and then send your
comments to the chair
so that we all we have one depository
for all the comments
or or send it to the whole committee
email address so we'll see it as well oh
okay all right yep and if the amendment
is ready on monday and it gets emailed
out sometime monday
then there'd be a chance to
add any comments um before we vote on it
tuesday morning
and then the whole committee could vote
on it on tuesday as well i suppose
and and i'd ask if
if there are any comments on it um
given the time frame if they're not if
it's not a substantial issue
i'd rather not go through this again
because
we're going to run out of time so
but if there's something seriously
broken then
hopefully not
[Music]
yep
and i'll send the email right after this
requesting
that that be scheduled so
all right if there's nothing else i will
close the subcommittee work session on
senate bill 282.
you